[Music]
do you um this might be a kind of an
older thing but does anybody here
remember what neopets was yeah i know
yes vaguely it wasn't it little game
yeah yeah yeah for sure to like compete
against pokemon a little bit or was it
like around the same time it might have
been around the same time
yeah it was more similar to tamagotchi
was kind of yeah
but they ended up making a website for
neopets and you would have your pet like
your whatever avatar pet on this site
and you could spend real world money to
like give it clothes a little cute
things
i didn't even know that was still around
but
yeah
everything really is it's the first half
huh it still gets four million visits a
month to this day and i thought it was
like i thought it was like dunsky yeah
it's still going people are still
spending money on i've never been on the
site i didn't even know those sites
should we all make one together
that's a recession dude oh yeah
the reason why i brought that up is
because a hacker recently stole the
personal data
of 69 million accounts
on the neopet site
yes neopets hackers are
ruthless bro there's 69 million users
69 million people got neopets yeah they
deserve it am i right
oh all right yeah you're right they
deserve to get hacked look at nerds yeah
69 million because there's a neopets
just got a tamagotchi dude you're fine
this hacker guy listed all the data on a
website for sale like dark web type [ __ ]
he's like hey selling 69 million
people's personal data what do you think
the price is for this dude
what do you think he wants i mean can it
fit in a terabyte a hard drive like i
mean that's a lot i mean it is just text
it's not going to heat up what do you
think what do you think the number is
there as an accountant let me do the
numbers med the numbers guy
ten million dollars ten million okay ten
man we got ten mil
one how much one
69 million people's personal debt i
think he's gonna i think he's going for
the for the billy oh wow no
69 million maybe it's just
is it exclusive
exclusive or he's an idiot he's like i
want
1
million if it's not exclusive i can kind
of see someone buying this for like 300
grand
so you could just keep selling it oh
i see what i mean no he is selling it
where like you have it it's yours
uh but here's the thing too you have to
take into account when you fence
something like that as in legally sell
it you kind of have to sell it cheaper
oh yeah
so it is a lot lower he's selling it for
four
bitcoins
that's it
in this market what's his email address
[Laughter]
it's like i'll buy right now i'll buy
right now
yeah that's like 80 grand yeah 80 grand
give me his email and
don't act surprise you guys when every
single one of our views starts getting
69 million views
exactly
neopet lovers yeah every video every
exactly 69 million views 30 comments
what the [ __ ]
if i was the owner of tamagotchi i'd buy
it because i want to revive my business
and these guys will probably i would
email them hey tamagotchi sale going on
now
yeah yeah email list
because neopets has been around for so
long i i mean how many of those are even
active they might be dead accounts
especially if they're net neil i mean
netgear accounts and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yahoo accounts yeah
angel fire
hotmail
yeah so here's what uh the data actually
has
email address password gender ip address
country and birthday of each one of
those no credit credit card
thingamabober i don't believe you could
throw the sickest events bro
with that list bro
throw a festival bro neo fast
fast let's go
it's the new fire fest and everyone gets
ripped off
oh my god isn't that more populations
than like most countries 69 million
people absolutely absolutely more than
most countries
yeah because neopets is global so i mean
before bitcoin though like inherently a
challenge like getting bitcoin for like
illegal things is you could track that
[ __ ] um you need to use monero
that's it
dude what what stop helping him what's
the website he's watching yeah you know
can i see what the vet the the neopet
they didn't say because they don't want
everyone to start buying illegal [ __ ]
but i want to see the neil's not the
dark oh neopets oh i thought you wanted
the i thought you wanted where he
was selling it i'm like damn do you want
this computer just blow up dude everyone
talks about the dark web but this is the
problem i have with the dark bed is i
want to visit but i don't want to see
[ __ ] child porn yeah because you know
they always in the welcome page you just
wanna you just wait on the welcome i
know there's the uh here's the neopets
site it has been replaced with a warning
data breach oh oh wow and then can you
go inside if you click it yeah well
child phone no i'm just kidding
it looks like that
oh
comic con
yeah
on mobile
that's tight looks nice very modern damn
they're still killing it man and there's
a hacker yeah just like that took over
all of that that's so messy i showed you
that like your internet security it's
such a cute brand can you imagine being
a hacker going to folk over this cute
branding little kid
i know it's pretty sad and i'm only
gonna charge them for bitcoin
have you guys ever seen the old silk
road when it was uh have you have you
well they have like i haven't seen it
when it was active but you can go
through like archives where it's kind of
like a museum it's showing you the
listings that used to be how do you even
go on the dark web so you need this this
browser called the only reason i know is
because my son
he was he was exploring the dark web
when he
it like opens on your computer and then
you have like another it's like opening
up another mozilla and you do it yeah
was he trying to buy an assassin
with bitcoin exactly like that so my kid
was like this was like years ago he's
like dad we should buy some bitcoin i'm
like this is before like i got in the
crypt it was probably 2015. it's like
why should we buy bitcoin he's like well
you could you could take bitcoin and on
the dark web you could buy expired us
dollars that they should have shredded
but they didn't so we could we could
spend yeah you could look at your son
man
he was like you could you could get five
thousand dollars a bitcoin and you could
exchange it for forty thousand dollars
of u.s dollars i'm like nah that was
your son harvey denver yeah dude
damn that's crazy
oh my god so you've been out you've seen
it what it looks like i didn't see it my
son was on it and so when he said dark
web i was like what is that like night
mode or something
[Laughter]
stupid i hate that that kind of works
it's evergreen
yeah dude so plus people don't really
like to mess around with tor browser
because sometimes you can open your own
[ __ ] up to vulnerability by even using
it oh [ __ ] and then people could just
[ __ ] with you but what if you have a vpn
brought to you by if you buy express
because yeah are we safe if we have a
vpn so you gotta do it at the library or
something yeah the safest way to buy
expired us dollars
go to your local library
i want to see what's on there because it
seems like something that it's like hey
guys um selling assassin's work and then
so well that's what [ __ ] up silk road
silk road was doing okay until they
started selling drugs actual killings oh
you could just kill someone right but
they were selling drugs too right yeah
but they didn't really get [ __ ] with
that bad until the person who uh ran
silk road started ordering
assassinations himself yeah
she really looked into that way yeah
like wait he was trying to get a hit on
himself
that's it just just a quality test his
own search
come on show me what you got
five stars
stop it's okay you're good
the dark web is just filled with idiots
the content is just so ridiculous i'm
trying to get some expired dollars
but total idiot
no yeah it's like when they were they
got away with uh selling drugs and all
kinds of illegal [ __ ] like you could buy
uh
like uh credit card skimmers you can buy
like blanks if you wanted to like clone
a credit is the dark web uh similar to
the black market
yeah so it's basically the electronic
black market
wow
one of my neighbors bought bitcoin
originally i think in 2013 or something
on the silk road for about a dollar each
oh man wow [ __ ] that feels crazy what a
scumbag that guy and he still
did so he obviously made some crazy yeah
he's doing all right he's holding his
brain's insane though like uh because
when it was like when bitcoin was at
like
60 70 grand i'm like you know you're
like
[ __ ] wealthy like a [ __ ] like
why do you even work yeah because he
sells uh he does he sells machinery
for uh like cannabis grow ops yeah
um and then he goes well i'm waiting for
it to get to the amount where i can buy
an island
wow and i'm like man your brain your
brain just works on a different level
than mine let me know when he's like
having
an emotional day bro let me hang out
with you
does he need an assistant moment yeah
yeah i'll be his assistant i can get him
coffee but you guys share these stories
where like some guys are that are
selling pot and stuff like that on the
silk road they got arrested went to jail
but they stole their bitcoin they get
out of jail like 10-15 years later and
then they have a ton of bitcoin wow
that sounds like a good deal what is the
silk road jail forced them to hold yeah
that's the
online
black market have you guys seen that
people are doing the same thing as silk
road but with snapchat accounts what
really yeah they sell drugs using
snapchat
oh because there's a premium side of it
i've heard exactly
[Laughter]
what subscribe to everything
[Music]